[Music]
hey Luke here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel today we're going to
talk about survival skills or prepping
I'm gonna give you some tips and tricks
and talk to you about common pitfalls
and the only thing I can do is to drink
my own pee now first off before we get
started I want to talk to you about the
two motivations for getting into
survivalist skills or preppy one is
entertainment and the other is more
practical okay and both reasons are
equally valid and most of us have a
mixture of those two motivations I love
going out in the woods and learning how
to rub sticks together and make fire
that's cool okay but this video is gonna
focus on the practical side and I want
to give you tips for practical survival
situations where your goal is actually
to avoid being in a situation where your
family is starving or in need when
people are getting into practical
survival skills are practical emergency
preparations the biggest mistake they
make is getting overly fixated on
unlikely but very dramatic risks we tend
to ignore big risks that are common and
focus on unusual risks that are more
dramatic and this is a mistake you
should not make when you're getting into
emergency preparation remember surviving
is not just something we do in the woods
and the risks that we face to our
survival aren't just out in the woods
there's things that we face every day
and most of them aren't big and scary
they're dull and mundane and everyday
but those are the risks we should be
preparing for the most so let's go to
the Center for Disease Control's website
look at some basic statistics about how
people are dying here in the United
States in 2016 the top 10 causes of
death were this number one was heart
disease with 635 thousand people number
two cancer
five hundred ninety eight thousand
people accidents
number three 161 or 161 thousand people
chronic lower respiratory disease killed
154,000 stroke 142,000 Alzheimer's
disease 116,000 diabetes eighty thousand
influenza pneumonia 51,000 nephritis or
nephrotic syndrome fifty thousand an
intentional self-harm or so
side was 45000 what's not on this list
homicide homicide didn't make the top
ten list of causes of death in the u.s.
in 2016 if you go to the FBI's website
15,000 people died in 2016 from homicide
this means that in 2016 in the United
States you are three times more likely
to kill yourself than to be killed by
somebody else this also means that you
were 42 times more likely to die from
heart disease than to be murdered if
avoiding an early death is actually your
goal then what you should be doing first
is eating a healthy diet getting regular
exercise avoiding tobacco and alcohol
and getting screened and examined
regularly to try to detect cancers early
eating your veggies is not as much fun
as stockpiling ar-15s but it's much more
likely to save your life so basically
the point I'm trying to make is that you
and your family should sit down and try
to figure out what are the biggest
threats the biggest risks you are facing
right now and prepare for those
emergencies first before you get too
caught up in the big dramatic
emergencies and for me personally that
was financial emergencies I've seen tons
of people ruined financially by loss of
job by injuries or health issues by
downturns in the economy and living
paycheck to paycheck is a very
precarious way to provide for your
family and so having us at least a
six-month supply of money where if I
lost my job we could live for six months
was priority number one when it came to
preparing for emergencies in my family
and before you go off and spend money on
on food supplies and building bunkers
and that sort of thing you really should
have your family on good solid financial
ground probably the second most
important thing we prepared for was
medical emergency so I bought this first
responders kit and I've been trying to
learn how to use it and learn first aid
and that sort of thing because frankly I
have three small boys and we're all into
crazy stuff if you watch our videos you
know that and I have used this a lot so
having a good medical kit that's more
than just band-aids and aspirin is an
important thing and it's not super
expensive
I got this bag for $90 and I
supplemented it with a few extra things
but for about 90 to 150 dollars you can
get a real bang-up first responder bag
that will take care of some serious
medical emergencies let me show you
what's inside I bought this bag on
amazon.com it'll put a link in the
description to where I got it but let me
show you what's inside so the first
thing you'll notice is we have very
large bandages and medical dressings
surgical dressings that sort of thing I
mean this is big stuff okay
and that's what you want because this is
to prepare for really serious
emergencies not just little boo-boos one
of the first things I bought to
supplement this emergency kit was this
burn dressing this stuff is amazing one
of the first things you need to do if
someone's seriously burned is you need
to cool down that burn slap this stuff
on there and then rush them to the
hospital and that will reduce the
severity of the burn and the likelihood
of scarring so this is something I keep
a lot of these around because I mean
let's face it what someone in this
family is getting burned before they
turn 18 it's going to happen sorry this
is such a mess I use this thing so much
it's all torn apart so another product
that I added to my medical bag to make
it a little bit better as quick clot
this stuff if you throw it on an open
wound it reduces the bleeding
dramatically so if someone's cut
themselves and they're really bleeding
badly you slap this on there and rush
them to the hospital and apply pressure
and it could save their life
so with serious bleeding this stuff is
absolutely gold okay I'm glad I'm doing
this video because I just realized my
big bottle of iodine has been taken out
of here but we like I said we use this a
lot so I have a lot of antiseptics like
back pain and hydrogen peroxide this
little spray bottle is like $1 at
Walmart I really need more medical tape
that's one thing I've noticed about
these bags is you burn through medical
tape way faster than you do bandages in
here I've got lots of medications and
odds-and-ends
another thing to include in your medical
kit is any special medications that your
family members might need one of the
biggest causes of non violent deaths
here in the US in emergency
is from people with special medical
needs where they get cut off from their
medications they have an asthma attack
and they don't have the rescue inhaler
because they ran out you know or they
they don't can't get their insulin or
you know their stroke medication or
whatever it is so make sure any chronic
conditions you have you have a little
bit of a supply of medication handy
during most disasters here in the United
States people end up getting evacuated
out of their home so having a good
portable 72-hour kit will help make the
evacuation process more comfortable and
safe and we've got a hodgepodge of
72-hour kits that we've kind of just
added one as our family has grown we've
got little ration bars for enough food
for an adult for 72 hours we got water
in here and some you know lots of little
odds and ends applies there's even a few
of these that have little kids toys and
stuff inside them if you want to buy
them they range anywhere from fifty to
four hundred dollars depending on what
you want to get or you can go to Walmart
and assemble yours for not that much
money if you want to supplement your
72-hour kits you're gonna need more
water and more food you need something
that's portable and it can be prepared
with minimal tools or fuel so to do that
I've got these water filtration systems
I've got this water bottle it has a
filter inside you put dirty water inside
drinks clean water we've got the
LifeStraw product which you can just put
one in and dirty water and you suck
through the straw and it cleans it or
you got more heavy-duty backpack filters
like this one that we could pump a
larger quantity of water which is good
for families when it comes to food
that's portable and easy to prepare
there's two different options one is
ration bars this is 3600 calories right
here and they're in little portions and
they last like 20 years and you don't
need any fuel you don't need to cook
them you can just eat them on the go and
it'll keep you keep you going they don't
taste that bad we actually did a taste
test video where I bought a bunch of the
different brands and I got the two
brands that we enjoyed the most so our
family of five can live six days eating
nothing but these eating them every meal
for a week would be quite tedious so we
also have of these things these mountain
house dehydrated meals they have an
extremely
long shelf life that lasts years and we
enjoy them so we use them camping as
well so we have a month worth of
dehydrated food and you've got breakfast
and beef lasagna and chicken teriyaki
and we just have a little emergency prep
stove with some butane fuel and stuff
you just grab grab these buckets and
you're off having water is more
important than having food in most
emergency situations so I've got this 35
gallon drum here and then I got these
six gallon jerry cans I picked up at
Walmart I've got this hand pump back
here to get the water out of the drum if
I need 35 gallons is a nice size because
even though it's really heavy
I can physically lift this on my own we
also have an absolute ton of bottled
water having a couple really sturdy fire
safes is also very important you can
keep your titles to your car your boat
and the deed to your house in here birth
certificates additionally having a
couple thousand dollars cash available
of course you want all those things safe
and protected all right say hi Tommy hi
okay behind me and Tommy is our food
storage so you can see here we've got a
lot of canned food what do you got over
there Tommy need lots of juice boxes if
you have young kids can't can't survive
a disaster without that we've got some
rice and oil
we've got toiletries and soap and
plastic forks and trash bags and things
like that there you go but thank you the
nice thing about food storage is it
doesn't really cost you anything we're
all gonna use this food anyways it's
part of our normal food budget the nice
thing is we can buy stuff in bulk and
save a little bit money and shop around
and get stuff on sale but as long as you
don't throw it away it doesn't cost you
any extra money you're just buying your
food a little bit in advance and having
a little bit of a stockpile of it one of
the really nice things to have in your
food storage is out of a ton of garbage
bags not only are they just really
useful but if your toilet doesn't work
you can lay this inside the toilet bowl
and then just put down the seat and use
your toilet normally then pick this up
take it out and burn it in the backyard
and
that's what a lot of people had to do up
in Alaska during the 1960's earthquake
you may have noticed all these boxes
stacked up here in the corner these are
full of number 10 cans full of staples
like freeze dried raspberries freeze dry
peas flour beans sugar we most of these
were bought from the Church of Jesus
Christ of latter-day saints I mean my
family were members of the LDS Church
and the church is really big on
promoting independence and emergency
preparedness and things like that and
they have these distribution centers
where you can go and get stuff like this
really cheap it's like at cost I'll make
sure to put links in the description of
various locations where you can buy this
sort of thing including the LDS
distribution center another great way to
supplement your 72-hour kit is just to
have a go bag full of camping gear this
has a tent bags mats pillows and a stove
with a little bit of butane and some
matches this is our basic camping here
we use it all the time when I want to go
camping with my boys I just grab this
bag throw it in the car we're ready to
go and it's enough for the whole family
another fun little device is the Kelly
Kettle this is a wood-burning stove it's
great for heating and cooking and use
very little fuel a handful of sticks
will allow you to cook an entire meal
off it I did a video on this I'll put a
link in the description we've lived our
house seven years and we've had three
major power outages we have above ground
power lines in our area lots of trees so
whatever there's a big windstorm or ice
storm there's lots of people lose power
and it could take days for power to come
back on and well it's not necessarily a
survival issue it's a comfort issue so
we got this generator for less than
$1,000 and we had a professional hook it
up to the house so that when it turns on
it safely provides a limited amount of
power to the house enough to run the
refrigerator a space heater some lights
electronics so we can watch movies and
not have all of our food go bad and it
runs off of gasoline or propane and we
use propane because gasoline goes bad
the all the ethanol makes it go bad
after you know six months or so so I can
store a propane pretty much definitely
on my property
and it'll always be good and I don't
need any permits to store it if I have a
big gasoline tank on my property I need
to get permits because it's an
environmental hazard propane you don't
and I can use these propane bottles to
run a barbecue to run the heater in my
garage to run you know cooking stuff so
it's really great when it comes to self
defense I don't have a lot of cool stuff
to show you I'm thankfully in a
situation where I'm not worried about
home invaders and things like that but
if you are in a situation where you feel
that's necessary make sure you get the
proper training there's a lot of great
self-defense courses out there
additionally I understand the laws
because the laws are tricky in most
places self-defense is guilty until
proven innocent not innocent until
proven guilty it's what we refer to as
an affirmative defense and additionally
make sure you keep your firearm secured
out of the hands of children there's a
lot of great products on the market
allow you to have your firearms readily
available but secure but anyway I hope
you guys enjoyed this video and learn
something new if you want to see all of
our survivalist emergency prep videos
check out our playlist I'll put a link
in the description and we put out new
videos every Saturday mornings thanks
for watching guys have a great time and
don't forget to click Subscribe if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor boys youtube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]